getting
[Music]
together
close my eyes into discussion
[Music]
looking like Chicken Little obliterated
instrumentals then I beat the systems
this is typical
uh braggadocio rap gubbins is like
scraps celebrity give it his uh
kind of a flighty person they kind of
similar to a babble monster rabbit means
tired I can't get out here NBA young boy
internet and we lying about these words
they could easily research jump right
back in it at the craps table the dump
pass was hidden but then I wrote the
level sixes man you better move your
chips I've had these conversations at
the crafts table too that's a real convo
but it's been times where I started
heating up and I start rolling
and somebody they keep all bad and
adults and I'm like man
man I don't know if you see what the
[__] is going on over here dog but